every school child knows that when
you're on trial there are two options
guilty and not guilty but apparently not
judge Eileen Cannon unfortunately judge
Canon forgot to give a jury a not-
guilty option judge Canon who was
overseeing the trial involving former
president Donald Trump's handling of
classified documents failed to include
the option of not guilty on the verdict
form provided to the jury as you can see
the language on the verdict form
includes a series of yes or no questions
but never allows the jury to find the
defendant not guilty the defendant
Christopher Wilkins was predictably
convicted now it's hard to overstate
just how bad this is from an appeal
perspective and not surprisingly the
defense is appealing saying how far does
someone have to go to school to say that
a verdict form is supposed to say guilty
and not guilty that would be one of the
most egregious versions of jury
instruction error but let's give judge
Canon a break here she's only presided
over four criminal trials that have
resulted in a jury verdict so you know
when this happens you need a good lawyer
but if you want a great lawyer let my
firm the eagle team take care of it the
link is in the comments and the bio